Timothy chalamet shows off his dance
moves that's what it is to be young over
the weekend the actor was spotted with
his Dune co-stars Zendaya that Z right
there and her assistant Darnell
appling's birthday party the theme
Freaknik
all day
at one point Timothy made his way to the
dance circle to show more of how he gets
down
[Music]
an eyewitness tells ET Timothy was
dancing with the crowd and enjoying the
music and he wasn't being shy he was
having a great time I have fun with it
that's true as for the whereabouts of
Timmy's rumor new lady love Kylie Jenner
well the eyewitness adds she was not at
the party he was just with Z I can't
it's no surprise Timothy and Zendaya are
hanging out outside of work the two
formed a close Bond while filming the
first dune film I don't believe
but I want you to Die With Honor
you know we had already been in the
desert maybe three four weeks and I was
just super grateful as Zendaya got there
I was getting along with everyone I
don't want to sound ageist but it was
great to have a you know uh someone oh
no about the same age and also her
assistant Darnell we just had a we had a
really great time and obviously on set
took the material as seriously as
required but then offset we were you
know losing our minds
and fans will get to see more of that
connection in the upcoming sequel it's
breathtaking
[Music]
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
Dune part two hits theaters in November
and while we wait to see Timothy riding
sand worms we can enjoy his sweet moves
foreign